[Music]
let's go to gail in jacksonville florida
hey gail what's up
hello how are you i'm remarkable how are
you i'm getting by i feel like i checked
almost all of the boxes you mentioned to
begin with except for going and coming
home from work today well welcome to the
gang i'm glad you're with us
so what's up how can i help
okay um so i need a little advice or
help on uh
how we reestablish trust
um reestablish
some
boundaries and rebuild some trust with
our teenager okay
so what happened
a lot
um so she got suspended from school
uh first time ever this has never
happened um she's typically a good kid a
be honorable uh
you know goes to school does her thing
comes home she does all her chores she's
a great kid
but she apparently shared
uh texted
a picture of one of her friends that i
guess she was having a falling out with
um
it was a nude picture or partially nude
and she shared it with another friend
okay
and then found out that that friend was
going to send it to somebody else and
that the girl that was in the picture
uh was about to go to the authorities so
she turned herself in we didn't know all
of that to begin with but she just said
she did the right thing she turned
herself in she didn't want it to get out
of hand but
really it came down to it was about to
come out anyways okay
so
uh that's what happened to begin with
she
she got suspended luckily the parents
didn't press charges uh it didn't go
crazy out of hand
but she did get suspended for a few days
we had some major
talks um
totally took away her phone um
the school had went through her phone
her dad went through her phone
but then when i went through her phone i
discovered that the reason they didn't
find these things is because she had
deleted the app
um
so
we had her write down all of her
passwords to everything
i went through all of her apps
everything um
found a lot of
snapchats tick tocks like three
different snapchats tick tocks uh
multiple
apps with
explicit
screen names and some
pretty trashy photos and she had
well over a thousand followers
and this is a very introverted kid very
introverted
you know so we
explained to her the dangers of all of
this you know thought that we we do a
good job talking and communicating and
things but uh
um
then we discovered uh after that uh we
thought we took all the appliances but
turns out she still had her air paws and
another iphone
took those from her
then i discovered she goes to her mom's
every weekend
and i found out that she had another
iphone over there and an ipad over there
um so i set the screen time turned all
that stuff off told her to bring the
other iphone back she brought it back
went through everything
and then
uh found out that there was some
pictures and videos in there of her
smoking weed
um
with this friend that her mom felt like
she was a bad influence and and she kind
of was yeah um the friend was smoking
weed and we knew that her her parents
did but uh or her dad anyways yeah um
but she never goes
does these things with us it's only it's
only when she's at her mom's honestly
all these pictures all these videos all
this stuff now i'm sure that when she's
at our house she yeah
i would say that you that you know of
right
right right well all the all the
pictures i mean i can tell in the
background and where she's at and
everything yeah so let's fast forward to
today
um well before we get to today is
her mom on board with this
no no not at all she grounded her for
one week after the original
uh nude situation came out but when when
mom saw found out about all her accounts
and all of the pictures she's posting of
herself and all that there was nothing
no it's all good no she she kept her
home for the weekend
um
basically to babysit her other child so
she can go out and do her thing okay um
so and then told her the next week she
could go to hang out with her friends
now whenever he
confronted you know told showed her mom
the pictures of the girl that she
thought was a bad influence he's like
listen yeah this is why you're you're
right she is a bad influence you know
we've known this for a while but yet you
still keep letting her go over there you
still keep letting her do things with
this kid and look these are the videos
to show you of what she's doing with
this kid
and she got very defensive about it she
thought he was attacking her parenting
and he is
yeah and i'm attacking everyone's
parenting all right so here's here's let
me give you some context and
then uh
i don't think the legal part of this is
over
i think there was probably a lot of
pressure to not make this a big deal and
if you don't say anything this can kind
of go away
this is the kind of thing that will
resurface
and
while your daughter is really lucky that
they didn't press charges i kind of wish
they had of
right because that's the only way
this is such a big deal
it's such a big deal
um
for a thousand different reasons
here's
so imagine this imagine you all had a
neighborhood
and in your neighborhood there was the
occasional burglary there was the
occasional
you know somebody got in in a fight
and so
let's say you had a loaded gun in your
house just in case
just in
case i have that okay just in case
right
and then you thought you know what's a
good idea let's give it to our 15 year
old she should carry it
um
we'll just tell her about it
we'll just tell her hey make good
choices
um but uh just in case
would would anybody do that
no no and i i've heard you explain this
in in another one of your shows uh
giving a kid a chainsaw
i explained that yeah to him as well
because i've been saying for a long time
you need to monitor this you need to
look at this this isn't this isn't about
monitor
this is scorched earth
any any other screen that is given to
this child
this child any other screen that she has
access to at all period is a choice for
an adult to ruin her life
because she's a kid
the fact that she's an introvert i could
care less you know what she has
a thousand people
saying we see you and we think you're
beautiful
a thousand people
telling her that she's got validation
through their thumbs up or their heart
emojis or through their private dms or
whatever
and i don't care what kind of parent no
parent can compete with that
especially a parent
dealing with divorced home and who loves
me and who's given me what i want and i
want this parent makes me eat vegetables
but this one makes me eat pizza so i
love them more all that she's a kid
and so
if i'm you i
it's not about challenging stepmom i
mean real mom's parenting
it's not about that
it's about saving this little girl
and i would go as far as to take those
pictures to the authorities and say this
is happening at this other person's
house
like i mean you hear what i'm saying
this is not about preserving like i
don't want to get her in trouble i don't
embarrass her we are so far past that
i'd call the cops i'd call the i would
get my attorney and say hey we need to
resurface this because mom is putting my
daughter in an unsafe situation is that
gonna do anything no it's gonna be drama
and a bunch of nonsense but that's the
level i'm at because here's what we're
doing now now i wanna paint a picture
that 10 years later
if my daughter's not in jail if my
daughter's not involved in stuff that
she can't walk back
i want to have a trail of honey i fought
for you
i went to court for you i called the
police for you i did everything from you
and this little 15 year old
is that all she's 15 16 how old is she
15. she'll be 16 soon yeah gosh
this little 15 year old
is gonna feel like you are ruining
everything
and this little community of hers is
thousand people who likes to look at her
erotic pictures and all
like this is her lifeline right now and
so when you cut that off it's gonna feel
like the end of time for her both both
this isn't like oh this whiny kid's no
this is like gonna be an emotional
physical thing her brain will scream
reconnect reconnect reconnect that group
of people tells you that you have value
and yes if my
ex says i can't believe you're
challenging my parenting yes
yes and so are the courts and so the
police i'm gonna call everybody so is
the school
everybody
i'm just gonna i'm not gonna let you go
over there because i'm not gonna put my
kid in this you hear what i'm saying so
like it's this delicate dance and we've
got this history on it this is a baby
girl that is screaming for adults in her
life to act like adults
right you know what i'm saying and i
know that you're you're there trying to
cheer her
husband on and
trying to get him to cheer on
x right i know you're in a weird spot
i just don't hear that people are
ringing the bell loud enough
like the matrix y'all dodged bullets if
she doesn't go to if she doesn't go to
get a criminal record out of this
just whiffed and she'd done this a year
and a half from now
then she's trafficking child pornography
you know what i mean
oh yeah oh yeah such a big deal
it is a very big deal and you know a lot
more
issues that like i i don't know i guess
the question turns to
how do i
get him on board i guess because
screening is
let her go over there we know this is a
not good environment for her
you know she lives with a man
with a child
and tells her tells her daughter that
we're not really together we don't love
each other and now she's going to go on
a vacation
and wants to invite another man
and we're like we can't send you like we
need to know where you're going but he
he doesn't
seem to think that it's his job to get
involved in that well she wants to go
there for the weekend or she wants to do
this he has he has no other jobs on the
planet
that come before
protecting and saving my daughter
right
that's it i agree that's it
so
asking like
man
don't give a kid a loaded gun don't let
your kid go to a house where they give
kids loaded guns
in this i'm talking to you but i'm also
talking to the millions of people
listening to this
this is the same as if you go to your
in-laws or your grandparents or their
grandparents or your friends or i don't
care who it is
this young woman
is not going to i still think she's a
good kid does that sound crazy i still
think she's a good kid
yeah she's a 14 or 15 year old 16 year
old
young woman who's just trying to connect
with people
it's the adults in her life that are not
fighting for her
i agree so what i do with him
i would
i don't scream and i don't yell that's
just not how i operate in the world i
would scream and yell
if somebody has to rattle the adults in
this situation
and if you tell him i'm calling the
police and i'm taking these photos of
what's happening at that house with the
marijuana and the alcohol and the
the sexualized pictures of our teen
daughter over there i'm taking this to
the cops so they will go over there and
shut it down because you won't
the fact that your husband hasn't called
that other family and said my daughter
will never come to your home
and if i see this again i'm calling the
police on you
like what's he doing
you know what i mean like that's the
level of
like i'm not letting my 15 year old make
these hard calls because she's 15.
that's the level of
ringing the bells i'm calling the school
and saying i can't get any adult in my
in this daughter's in this young woman's
life with custody to protect her will
you help me because i'm a stepmom and
i'm watching this thing just get flushed
down the toilet because nobody seems to
care nobody seems to be fighting
nobody seems to be screaming and yelling
and banging on things
oh
i don't blame a 16 year old for taking
delicious photos i just don't cause
they're 16.
i blame the adults that handed him the
loaded weapon
man
i'm heartbroken for her because she's in
a in a cycle now
that she can't get out of because she's
a child
please please please adult somebody step
up for her all of you step up for her
please